Pee-wee Herman was an eternally youthful
figure and Paul Rubens always knew he
couldn't play the character forever
here's what he thought of a potential
successor as has recently been announced
by the actor's estate and several major
news outlets Paul Rubens has passed away
at the age of 70. the legendary comedian
and children's entertainer was best
known for creating and acting as the
youthful Pee-wee Herman a character he
played for the near entirety of his
career Once Upon a Time an actor's death
would mean the end of that character
appearing on screen again however with
some recent technological Evolutions
that's not necessarily the case 2016's
Rogue won a Star Wars story arguably
served as the first popular proof of
concept of this ethically dubious
practice with the late Peter Cushing's
likeness being recreated through CGI for
a supporting role Rubens actually
addressed this possibility somewhat in a
quasi-serious interview without click
magazine in 2020 roughly three years
after his cancer diagnosis when asked
could take up the role in his stead he
stated no one else will ever play Peewee
that would happen over my dead but oh I
see your point actually it's 20 20 now
the technology exists for me to be
computer generated and look completely
real however if I didn't have the budget
I've always liked the work of
Christopher Walken the two projects Paul
Rubens had seemingly been most fixated
on were two feature films both of which
were Pee-wee Herman stories the first
was peewee's Big Holiday which was
ultimately produced by Reuben's Aunt
Judd Apatow and distributed on Netflix
in 2016. it was a positively received
family adventure in the same vein as
1985's Pee-wee's Big Adventure You're
Gonna Leave Fairville
you're going to take a holiday the
second was an apparently darker film
called the Pee-wee Herman Story which
would have dealt with more adult
scenarios involving the titular
character's rise to fame and Fall From
Grace perhaps this would have taken
inspiration from Reuben's real-life
legal struggles which ultimately saw the
actor Retreat from the public eye for
several years there had also long in
development been a film based on his
playhouse series titled peewee's
Playhouse the movie which Rubens had
pitched to Paramount Pictures sometime
before 2007. the film would have
seemingly been somewhat separate from
the Big Adventures and the darker
Pee-wee Herman Story instead focusing on
the unique world and characters of the
Pee-wee's Playhouse series which
originally aired from 1986 to 1990. it
seems unlikely that any of these
hypothetical films would move forward
without Rubens involved however it
wouldn't be the first time a Peewee
performance was aided by CGI in a 2020
interview with Conan O'Brien Paul Rubens
revealed that his appearance in the 2016
film at peewee's Big Holiday had been
altered with the use of anti-aging CGI
technology similar to what was used on
the Martin Scorsese crime drama the
Irishman it wasn't done in service of
Reuben's ego however but to maintain the
childlike essence of the Pee-wee Herman
character he told Conan PB was sort of
based on Youth and youthfulness
apparently the process wasn't cheap with
Rubens claiming that it would have been
significantly less expensive for him to
get plastic surgery what is that what
what's involved I mean you couldn't
afford it really seriously he emphasized
that he wasn't joking about the price
either interestingly enough and I I
found this out in hindsight it cost so
much money to do it that it would have
been a fraction of the cause for me to
have had plastic surgery his youthful
appearance wasn't all algorithms and
polygons though Rubens also credited The
Talented lighting designers and makeup
team who used their craft in tandem with
the technology to bring the character of
PeeWee Herman back as we all remember
him peewee's big holiday is currently
streaming on Netflix
foreign